[Music]
that's acidic and your mom is it was a
hippie you grow up in that environment
it's not like a sitcom well yeah it was
hilarious it was very funny ya know I
grew up in Oakland California I'm from
interesting we got an applause break my
home can you love as I Drive by well I
mean I grew up in Houston that sound
effect makes less sense with each
passing year because of the effects of
gentrification like now it's a it's not
really it's more like I grew up in
Oakland latte this sounds have changed
yeah but I grew up in Oakland and then
my dad was in was in Brooklyn actually
well one thing is interesting when I was
on the show before promoting my book
catcher in the rye there some people are
laughing because there's a similarly
titled book is that right so weird
coincidence I found out about that yeah
now sing yeah was the first thing I
found out after I wrote my book I
checked it out it's called Catcher in
the Rye gave it a read yeah not not a
fan not even close
mine's a banger though you should
definitely check it out put it up put it
up but yeah my dad was that was a
Hasidic Jew he got very religious as we
got older and it was a very weird
bifurcated experience because my dad was
extremely religious and my mom was like
very open atheists like very like into
like like sex and sexuality like very
porous but look we never slept together
but like when then I got to masturbation
age I get like at that age that my
mother started to think like oh he's
getting the hormones are starting again
she brought me with her to like a one of
these feminist vibrator like feminist
sex toys you know what I'm talking know
what I'm talking I know exactly I know
yeah their discomfort but I lived
through this yeah my mother took me on a
field trip to the vibrator store to buy
me a lesbian text-based erotica to help
you with your self pleasuring yeah but
my question is okay she went to a
vibrator how did she even know where the
vibrator store was what do you mean how
did she know I mean she definitely was
an a lawyer loyal customer she had a
punch our she would go
yeah she had a punch card yeah but it
was kind of shaky a little bit I wish it
was just for my pornography oh yeah
because the truth is she was she was
very sexually open and stuff and she she
would always buy a Kouta mom for her
Hitachi Magic Wand vibrate my mother's
deaf by the way you remember that my
mom's deaf yeah you remember the Hitachi
Magic Wand oh I need to mention to you
that it is the loudest vibrator
available on the market and that my
mother has no concept no connection of
the concept of sound whatsoever this was
my childhood you grew up
see if that got going on mom's got the
Hitachi in the other room there's all
kinds of noise and then dad
Hasidic Hasidic Hasidic very good and
what's that experience like when you go
and you live with dad so when I go to
dad you know that's much less actually
open environment but I was already full
I had already flowered as a young lady
and so I started doing this thing where
you we didn't have the internet so I
started like calling these phone sex
line so I was very young you remember
calling phone sex lines from your dad's
house yeah I'm not proud of it at all
but I got to the age where it was like
Bar Mitzvah age and I started to come
alive and and so I started calling these
numbers but they had this workaround
where you you know the parents blocked
all the 900 number so they made this
workaround where you would call these
long-distance phone numbers and someone
in some far-off exotic location would
answer and what the best call I ever
made I called a number and the woman
picked up she's like oh lo or what I
don't know I don't do voices very well
so what country do you think she was
from I'm gonna say probably like the
bora bora maybe yeah very very expensive
by the way and she I called her and I
was like hello I'm hello I'm a grown up
man I'm not 13 I'd like to have sex on
the phone with you please mmm and she
was like oh no sorry I don't do that
kind of call she doesn't do that kind of
call I mean there's only one why did
they connect you to her if she doesn't
do that kind of I don't know what
happened if there was a weird
I don't know I have no idea I there was
only one logical thing to do which
wasn't embarrassed get hang up the phone
move on to a new something uh I decided
to push the issue for some reason come
on please I already paid the connection
fee please and she's like no and I'm
like please she's like no and I'm like
please and she's like oh all right
we had phone sex at night Conan I still
don't know what happened that night did
I did I pull a woman out of retirement
for one last mode or even more
compelling an idea that I call a random
wrong number in the Philippines and some
saint of a woman could hear the the pain
in my voice the two deaf parents the
Hasidic dad the Deaf mom just thought
you know what
this kid needs it go ahead and push me
kid puck away
[Applause]
you